no aparente tranquilidad se respira en
Santa Cruz calles vacías y bloqueos con
neumáticos marcan el panorama de la
ciudad boliviana luego de que choques
entre opositores y oficialistas esta
mañana se dieran al inicio de la huelga
en la región
los manifestantes que se tomaron las
calles exigen un nuevo censo Con
urgencia de hoy empezó un paro Cívico
con bloqueos
exigiendo que se realice en Bolivia un
censo en el primer semestre del 2023
mayores recursos y escaños en el
parlamento del país son dos de las
razones por las cuales los manifestantes
demandan un censo y aseguran que la
región la más poblada del país se está
viendo afectada por datos
desactualizados Porque nosotros
necesitamos más recursos esta este
departamento Santa Cruz es muy grande y
los recursos están muy limitados para la
salud la educación la huelga ha dividido
opiniones dentro de la población
expresadas de manera violenta y tanto la
ONU como la Unión Europea han condenado
los hechos
ONU Bolivia lamenta la pérdida de una
vida humana y exhorta a los actores
políticos y sociales a evitar escenarios
de confrontación y violencia que pongan
en riesgo el orden público y la vida de
las personas en paralelo se ha
instaurado una mesa de diálogo entre los
dirigentes del comité cívico y
representantes del gobierno de Luis Arce
que busca calmar los ánimos entre la
población el presidente ha asegurado que
el censo solo podrá realizarse en 2024
la división que vivió Bolivia revive los
temores de la violencia política de 2019
cuando opositores de derecha denunciaron
un fraude en las elecciones de ese año y
acusaron como responsable al
izquierdista Evo Morales quien renunció
en medio de la crisis